vous êtes bien sur lcp public sénat
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
en compagnie de michaël szames est bon
jour que tian bonjour michael cette
semaine on reviendra sur les hésitations
du gouvernement concernant la réforme du
travail du code du travail la
présentation du projet de loi a été
repoussée pour donner plus de temps au
dialogue en tout cas officiellement le
texte visé syndicats mais aussi la
gauche les députés ont voté de nouvelles
mesures antiterroristes une personne
pourra être plus quatre heures après un
contrôle d'identité et les forces de
l'ordre pourront faire usage de leurs
armes hors du cas de légitime défense
est un projet de loi qui divise à gauche
mais aussi à droite
et puis comme chaque année le salon de
l'agriculture a rassemblé les foules et
attirer les responsables politiques
notamment à droite que les concurrents à
une éventuelle primaire se sont succédé
avec chacun sa proposition pour le monde
agricole
bonjour j'ai karoutchi vous êtes
l'invité cette semaine de part le bref
vous allez commenter évidemment toute
cette actualité vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine et katia évidemment
l'actualité elle commence par un a dit
lundi avec ségolène royal qui relance la
polémique sur la durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires
trois mois après l'arrivée de la après
la coop 21 et l'arrivée de certains
écologistes au gouvernement la ministre
de l'environnement veut prolonger la
durée de vie des centrales nucléaires de
dix ans une déclaration qui a provoqué
des réactions germes andrieu c'est un
feu vert sous conditions mais qui offre
de nouvelles perspectives aux centrales
nucléaires françaises
leur durée de vie pourrait être prolongé
de dix ans si l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire donne son feu vert oui je
donnerais l'autorisation de prolongation
de dix ans de centrales qui sont déjà
amortis dans qui produiront une
électricité à meilleur marché mais dans
le contexte je le rappelle de la baisse
de la part du nucléaire de 75 à 50%
savoir la production des restes objecté
pour monter en puissance sur le
renouvelable
à l'arrivée un mix énergétique maintenu
avec une baisse de 75 à 50 % pour la
part du nucléaire d'ici 2025
l'écologiste jean vincent placé à peine
arrivé au gouvernement n'y voit pas une
remise en cause de la loi de transition
énergétique qu'il y aura quelques
centrales qui ont vocation à être
modernisés mais je conclus là dessus je
le dis aussi pour mes collègues du
gouvernement
attention la filière nucléaire
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est avec les
échecs de nos pères et en finlande et à
flamanville
c'est plutôt au bord de la faillite pour
que très sincèrement je vois même pas
comment va trouver l'argent pour
prolonger prolonger ou non les centrales
est avant tout une question de coût et
l'opération ne serait pas vraiment
rentable si on voulait prolonger de dix
ans leur espérance de vie si j'ose dire
il s'agit de faire une opération qui me
sont de lifting qu'on appelle le grand
carénage en langage nucléaire qui coûte
cent milliards d'euros c'est la cour des
comptes qui donne ce chiffre 100
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui le
nucléaire il faut comprendre et sortir
du mythe que c'est moins cher pour tenir
l'objectif de 50% sur la part de
nucléaire d'ici 2025
les seules fermetures prévues
aujourd'hui concerne les deux réacteurs
de la centrale de fessenheim chez vous
comprenez ça vous fait rire mais vous
comprenez vous comporter des
prolongations
qu'est ce qui vous fait rien d'abord
franchement on sait bien que en
prolongeant la durée de vie si
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire le le
garantie d'un certain nombre de
centrales
ça veut dire qu'on remet en cause le 75
qui passe à 50% ce pas sérieux de dire
dans neuf ans on sera passé de 75 à 50
sénateurs contre avec longeant les
centrales enfin ces mêmes fins de la
provocation imbécile de dire ça bon
deuxième élément ouais je trouve très
drôle vous fait rentrer 3 écolo des cas
3 et colloques sont entrain gouvernement
vous annoncer la prolongation de vie des
centrales nucléaires
je ne demandais si j'allais partir du
gouvernement aussitôt arrivé alors tu es
grand ils sont restés vous avez pu en
parler peut-être avec le connaissez mais
je ne parle pas de nucléaire avec jean
massart vous avez pas je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs qu'on ne soit pas en accord
absolu en la matière mais non je trouve
que voilà arrive un moment un peu de
sérieux ne nuit pas moi je suis pour le
fait que les centrales si on a des
certitudes puisse être prolongé
de là à dire que ça ne change rien aux
75 qui passe à 50 % que ça ne change
rien la politique écologique du
gouvernement
arrêtons la plaisanterie on n'a plus un
rond les caisses sont vides
on essaye de remettre en 2012 je bourre
faune le plus près on et voilà on essaie
de prolonger la durée de vie des
centrales pour avoir de l'électricité
moins chère
parce qu'il faut bien un moment qu'on
trouve de la ressource voilà je suis
d'accord c'est normal que ce soit
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire parce que
si un risque il faut évidemment pas le
faire enfin on sent bien que la
politique écologique de madame royal ou
de monsieur hollande s'arrête sur le mur
de la réalité de ce qu'on voudra les
nerfs train de dire que le nucléaire
c'est toujours les berlinois défi pour
l'énergie nucléaire donc je vais pas
commencer à hurler contre la
prolongation où les écolos les écolos ça
suffit comédien pendant un moment
nicolas sarkozy l'environnement ça
commence à bien faire des économies je
crois qu'il faut simplement il ya une
écologie réaliste il ya un environnement
possible
et puis il ya des réalités économiques
il ya des réalités qui sont là bon être
bien on avance et on arrête de faire du
dogmatisme écologique
d'ailleurs comme il ya plus personne
europe ecologie les verts sont pas très
grave
alors on va d'un autre sujet important
cette semaine c'est à mardi le
gouvernement a décidé comme vous savez
avec un dossier de reporter de deux
semaines le projet de loi elle comme
minime officiellement manuel valls
souhaite retravailler le texte est mieux
l'expliquer face à la grogne des
syndicats et d'une partie de la gauche
qui exige son retrait le texte être
présenté en conseil des ministres le 24
mars
état des lieux avec elisa bertreux mais
il avait assuré qu'il irait jusqu'au
bout
pourtant lundi face à la pression manuel
valls est obligé de reculer
le projet de loi elle connerie ne sera
plus présentée le 9 mars en conseil des
ministres mais le 24 15 jours de délai
de quoi laisser plus de temps à la
concertation
quand le texte est apparu il y a eu des
incompréhensions ce qu'a dit le chef de
l'état des incompréhensions des des
questions il faut avoir peur de discuter
de dialoguer rives
une critique à peine voilée de la
méthode musclée de manuel valls
le premier ministre a toujours dit qu'il
voulait aller vite sur ce texte
la dernière réforme majeure du
quinquennat de françois hollande
problème les partenaires sociaux ont peu
été consultés et certaine mesure les ont
très vite braquer on a le premier
ministre qui va encore une fois à coups
de menton en dix ans et je aller
jusqu'au bout et vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir depuis huit jours après
on retire le texte on dit maintenant il
faut prendre le temps du débat de la
concertation c'est dommage qu'il n'y ai
pas pensé il ya eu ce jour 1 qu'il
fallait concertée une occasion manquée
d'aboutir à un texte consensuel y
compris avec les parlementaires
l'ailé gauche du ps s'oppose fortement à
certaines mesures
au point pour le gouvernement de laisser
entendre qu'il pourrait passer en force
si les parlementaires faisaient de la
résistance de quoi braquer davantage les
députés la ministre
elle tient bon je suis pas là
aujourd'hui pour vous donner l'issue de
ces concertations alors même qu'elle
commençait il faut être dans ce dialogue
je suis ministre du dialogue social et
ce dialogue social est essentiel quinze
jours de dialogue donc pour négocier et
trouver des compromis et tenter de
pacifier les relations du gouvernement
avec les syndicats et avec sa majorité à
l'égard d'autres si manuel valls
semblait aller vite avec ce texte
finalement il est reporté officiellement
pour donner plus de temps au dialogue
un commentaire sur la méthode n'est pas
le sentiment que malone il faut arrêter
de se fiche du monde
enfin ce gouvernement nous a dit à
quatre cinq mois vous allez voir on va
réformer le code du travail
on s'y met tout de suite qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pendant quatre cinq mois
parce que d'un coup d'un seul on a
découvert ya huit jours que y avait pas
eu de concertation avec les syndicats y
avait pas eu assez de concertation au
sein du ps avait pas eu mais ils ont
fait quoi par an 4 5 mois des bouffes
ils ont craint personne
entre eux ben alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait un texte de loi ça se prépare
c'est avant que ça arrive aux conseils
des milices que s'est concerté travail
et découvrir au moment de passer aux
comptes est mise qu'il a été concerté
avec personne
c'est absolument invraisemblable et
d'ailleurs c'est pas crédible
moi je pense qu'à réalité il ya eu de la
concertation il ya eu des discussions et
qu'ils ont voulu passer outre et comme
manuel valls a dit moi il me faut des
espaces il me faut de la libération de
l'entreprise parce qu'il faut inverser
la courbe du chômage parce que sinon on
lance des résultats parce qu'il faut des
résultats
donc je passe en force et puis ils
voient qu'il ya des réactions
hollande qui se met en retrait en diola
là oh la la qu'est ce qui se passe au
point qu'il faille qui déjeunent
ensemble soit disant pour se rabibocher
mais où est-ce qu'on est le premier
ministre à se rabibocher avec le
président sur un texte aurait dû être
travaillé avant sur un test sur l'avant
projet duquel j'avais dit après tout si
ça reste comme ça pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas sauf que maintenant on ne sait plus
du tout ce qui aura dedans
donc en fait d'une prudence extrême et
on va attendre de voir ce qui met dedans
moi je crains qu'un texte qui était soi
disant fait bon
le dialogue dans les entreprises pour
une véritable d'un véritable
assouplissement pour que les entreprises
puissent créer de l'emploi
au bout du bout finissent par plus de
réglementations plus de contrainte parce
qu'on a écouté tout le monde parce
qu'ils veulent pas de valve
parce que l'unef fait peur parce qu'on
veut pas une manif dans la rue juste
parce que hollande et discréditer parce
que le gouvernement n'a plus aucun point
parce qu'il ya plus de majorité à
l'assemblée
parce que c'est la fin des temps et que
on a compris on connaît les 2016 c'était
une année noire ou blanche comme vous
voulez mais je l'est parce qu'il a plus
de majorité pour gouverner et il ya plus
de gouvernement digne de leur a pas de
majorité n'y aura pas de majorité sur ce
texte
mais où parce que son papa de juillet
mais à l'asthme est d'abord j'attends de
savoir quel est le texte que je vous
dise oui oui le texte c'est quoi le
texte s'il enlève tous les éléments
d'assouplissement pour mettre que des
éléments de contrainte je veux pas ce
texte devienne moins jeunes couraient
dans la rue ça peut terminer comme le
cpe à l'épaule et ses comparses à avec
le cpe le cpe a été retiré quand y avait
eu un mois de manif
là on retire un texte avant même qu'ils
aient une manif on est encore plus fort
que fort à bientôt il fera une manif
virtuelles sur facebook et le
gouvernement une pétition d'ailleurs qui
atteint près gouvernements puissants
capables autoritaire qui va faire bouger
les choses en ce pays il ya un syndicat
étudiant qui dit si éventuellement vous
bougez pas je retire et je fais
descendre dans la rue et hop on a retiré
le thé club en italie à réformer ce pays
en italie matteo renzi alors par la
marché du tri mais la mauvaise mais c
est bien sûr contre eux d'abord alors
premiers éléments
reconnaissons que ce genre de texte 20
début de mandat un président élu sur un
projet mais ça dans son projet et
considère que dès le début du mandat il
faut le faire voter avec une majorité
solide et un gouvernement stable
je reconnais que faire vouloir faire
voter des choses lourdes en fin de
parcours quasi dans la période
électorale
quand on n'a plus de majorité quand le
sénat est opposée à la majorité
gouvernementale
ça devient le parcours du combattant et
quand en plus le parti dit majoritaire
n'existe
plus que par le fait de posséder un
immeuble parce que pour le reste y a
plus rien ils s'étripent je vois que les
députés quittent le parti d'ailleurs un
passé c'est mission impossible parce que
on sait pas ce que va être donné ce
texte à l'assemblée
et une fois qu'il se retirait de
l'assemblée verra bien ce qui se passe
au cépage etc a aussi écouté ce que
disait françois hollande en début de
semaine que vous réserve et je vais pas
me rassurer tout de suite on écoute
comme le texte a donné lieu à des
interrogations
c'est assez légitime à des
questionnements g comprend pourquoi le
premier ministre a prévu une
concertation vaut mieux prendre du temps
pour mieux en gagner et pour faire en
sorte que ce soit à la fin la france
qu'ils puissent réussir ensemble les
organisations syndicales les
organisations également patronales
seront reçus et puis il y aura une
conclusion qui forcément devra amener
les uns et les autres à prendre leurs
responsabilités c'est-à-dire à faire
ensemble que nous puissions avancer
moi j'aurai votre réaction sur une opra
ce qu'était dans à l'intérieur de cette
phrase prendre du temps pour mieux en
gagner
le texte est en préparation depuis six
mois ils pouvaient pas regagner en
préparant le texte vous attendez
d'annoncer le texte pour des remous fait
il vaut mieux le retirer pour rediscuter
parce qu'on va en gagner c'est à dire
que on a mis six mois on avait réussi à
rien faire on annonce on le retire on va
renégocier
donc ça veut dire qu'il sera même pas
prêt fin mars parce que si un mouvement
de grève le 31 on va essayer d'éviter de
panne on sait le texte avant donc on va
encore gagner du temps que vous disiez
tout à l'heure ce que vous disiez manuel
valls veut aller plus loin elle veut
pousser les feux jusqu'au réformateur
comment il se dit lui-même oui et alors
son nom mais le vrai sujet c'est que
depuis 2012
vous avez un ps qui en réalité tu en
deux blocs un bloc social libéral et un
bloc socialiste à l'archaïque bon ces
deux blocs ont essayé de coexister
aujourd'hui ne coexistent plus alors
vous avez un walsky d'un pousseur macron
sur madame elcom riz sorgho et puis de
l'autre côté vous avez les arcs qui
bouge pas bon d'être bien ça veut dire
que le présent hollande a été élu sur un
faux projet sur un projet qui n'était
pas capable d'imposer à son pensum
entend beaucoup à droite de c'est la
vérité c'est la vérité la preuve c'est
que même pour cette réforme du code du
travail
on sait ya six mois on est de droite
rejet des eaux dit même qu'il fait une
politique de droite françois hollande
non il fait pas de politique du tout il
va au fil de l'eau il n'y a plus rien
qui se fait l'état n'existe quasi plus
enfin écoutez la révision
constitutionnelle regarde enfin tout est
plus rien qui n'ont rien kitty alors on
va voir cette fois c'est une surprise
comme cette fois fait quelque chose
tiennent non c'est une surprise au sénat
la position du sénat cette semaine la
droite sénatoriale a changé de pied un
petit peu sur les pilotes et la
déchéance raisonnable vous allez y venir
on va regarder le petit sujet concret
par sophie normand quotidien l'est
républicain compter sur le sénat à
majorité de droite pour ramener à sa
version initiale le projet de révision
constitutionnelle édulcoré en février
par les députés socialistes
le patron des sénateurs l'est
républicain s'était engagé à
réintroduire la référence à la
binationalité mais à deux semaines du
début de l'examen du texte en séance
bruno retailleau y renonce nous
n'offrirons pas nous diront oui à la
déchéance mais non à l'apatridie
c'est à dire que nous nous inscrirons
pas les binationaux dans le texte de la
constitution ça peut choquer certains je
le comprends parfaitement mais nous
respecterons la parole du président de
république exprimée et j étais devant
tous les parlementaires à versailles
ils avaient dit non à l'apatridie eh
bien nous inscrirons dans le texte que
l'apatridie est interdite
une volte face qu'il justifie par le
refus d'une posture politicienne
une volte face qui pourrait rendre
possible la synthèse jusque là
impossible dans la classe politique
reste la question de la patrie dit que
les députés socialistes voulaient
supprimer
c'est autour de ce point que devrait
désormais se cristalliser le débat roger
karoutchi comment expliquez vous cette
volte face qui a pris un peu de cossette
en vol sincèrement c'est pas une
volte-face 1 nous disions dès le début
que ce soit sur l'état d'urgence
que ce soit sur la déchéance de
nationalité faut-il une révision
constitutionnelle
on n'est pas sûr mais comment ne voulait
pas donner le sentiment de bloquer
quelque chose qui allait dans le bon
sens
on a dit ok au discours du président de
la république au congrès et donc moi
j'avais dit
si la révision constitutionnelle prend
ces deux éléments je la voterai alors il
ya eu tous les carabistouilles à
l'assemblée au sein du ps et tous on n'y
comprenait plus rien on sait plus ce
qu'il voulait c'est chez vous non non
non pourquoi parce que nous la
commission des lois va réécrire et va
pas rétablir l'état d'urgence telles
quelles sans élément supplémentaire de
ce qui a été rajoutée à l'assemblée elle
va remettre la déchéance de nationalité
est comme un débat mais ça c'est vrai
qu'un débat sur est-ce que ça concerne
que les binationaux ou les monos
nationaux dont je puis dire qui est pas
un débat clos ni à gauche ni à droite je
reconnais eh bien on va simplement
mettre dans la révision
constitutionnelle que on autorise pas si
je peux leur dire l'apatridie alors est
ce que ça veut dire que ce texte réécrit
par la commission des lois du sénat puis
par le sénat lui-même dans quinze jours
est ce que ça veut dire que ce texte
trouve à une majorité à l'assemblée
parce que vous avez ma question est ce
qu'on va au congrès je n'en sais rien
moi j'ai le sentiment profond
je peux me tromper que la gauche explosé
maintenant sur le code du travail
n'obéit plus à rien sur la révision
constitutionnelle et que vous verrez
qu'un certain nombre de gens au ps et
parmi les députés ps diront déchéance de
nationalité vie nationaux mollo
nationaux apatridie patrice et non vous
pensez sans leur âge je pense que on va
avoir beaucoup de mal à trouver pour
cette révision concessionnels d'une
majorité à l'assemblée maintenant quelle
que soit la rédaction du sénat c'est
pour cela que la rédaction un petit peu
changé c'est que vous êtes sages ont dit
il faudrait quand même pas que le ps se
foutent de la gueule du monde trop
longtemps ils sont pas capables de se
mettre d'accord entre eux c'est quand
même pas nous qui allons porter la
responsabilité d'un éventuel échec sur
la déchéance de nationalité
parce qu'ils sont pas capables de se
mettre d'accord nous nous sommes
raisonnables nous nous avions dit oui au
début et on était jeune a été très clair
dans les différents responsables de
votre parti je pense à nicolas sarkozy
dont la jupe et qui n'était pas du tout
d'accord sur ce jouet mais les deux
avaient dit ni l'un ni l'autre ne sont
députés ou secteurs mais les deux
avaient dit que s'il était député ou
sénateur
-votre les deux les deux donc c'est pas
une question de division au sein des
républicains c'est vrai qu'on pouvait se
dire entre les articles du
code civil qui finalement permettre la
déchéance de nationalité et l'état
d'urgence qui a été validée par le
conseil constitutionnel
on n'a pas forcément besoin d'une
révision mais comme on ne voulait pas
être en arrière de la main et pas faire
de politique politicienne par rapport au
président la république
on avait dit si ça donne le sentiment
que le pays se mobilise contre le
terrorisme et contre tous les risques
c'est ok après on a assisté à la
pantalonnade à gauche donc que chacun
porte une responsabilité on va passer
aux mercredis vous propose d'aller faire
un petit détour par le salon de
l'agriculture
on va dire que c'est une forme de
tradition française presque un passage
obligé roger karoutchi les personnalités
politiques vont défiler eux aussi au
sein de l'agriculture à gauche comme à
droite certains ont été très bien
accueillis pour d'autres est un petit
peu plus difficile à regarder
ils y vont pour séduire l'électorat
agricole pour tester leur popularité
aussi le jour de l'inauguration du salon
hués et insultés
françois hollande a vite été fixée sur
la sienne pour l'upa qui nous écoute
plus
mais son élevage deux jours plus tard
son premier ministre évoque lui des
échanges rugueux mais respectueuse bien
des gens la gueule ouverte
son effectif et c'est normal qu'on les
entende et collante dans leur détresse
mais il faut aussi des remises en cause
à droite il y a comme un parfum de
primaire dans les allées du salon
la concurrence fait rage mercredi entre
vaches et cochons trois ténors du parti
les républicains déambulent sans jamais
se croiser nicolas sarkozy profite d'une
visite de sept heures pour proposer un
plan marshall de 100 millions d'euros
c'est un choix de vie ou de mort la
baisse des charges est indispensable
elle passera également par une
diminution des dépenses de but en blanc
aussitôt taclé par françois fillon
la seule priorité pour l'ex premier
ministre des mesures urgentes pour
sauver l'agriculture française record
d'assiduité pour bruno le maire l'ancien
ministre de l'agriculture passe trois
jours aux côtés des agriculteurs
de son côté alain juppé candidat lui
aussi à la primaire de droite et favori
s'y voit déjà en pleine crise agricole
le coupable est tout trouvé pour marine
le pen la présidente du fn parti à la
conquête des agriculteurs pendant près
de dix heures
maintenant engagée à violents bras de
fer avec bruxelles
parce que pour sauver la peau des
éleveurs et les agriculteurs pensait à
logan
c'est une évidence phil hogan le
commissaire européen à l'agriculture qui
ne s'attardera pas dans les allées du
salon préférence engouffré avec le
ministre de l'agriculture pour une
réunion de travail
de quoi boucler une semaine très
politique à la gauche était service
minimum à gauche à gauche à droite
pardon de service maximum normal
obligatoire sa salle une agriculture et
où elle a été politique on a vu depuis
franchement des semaines on semble
découvrir tous les angles tout le monde
et tous les responsables dont vous savez
ce que c'est encore nécessaire
sincèrement oui parce que pour les
parlementaires par exemple des zones
rurales oui il ya les agriculteurs de
leur région s'est pas seulement un
passage politique c'est aussi la défense
des produits de chaque région donc moi
je trouve que c'est que c'est bien
qu'une façon celle mesurée sur
l'affluence aussi et ça va se passer
auprès des médias parce que c'est là à
chaque fois on calcule plus de monde
pour alain juppé pour nicolas sarkozy
pour eux ça c'est plus les médias qu'ils
font que nous donc je sais pas si ça
évalue quoi que ce soit ça évalue la
colère du monde rural
beaucoup plus que de savoir pour qui ils
vont voter demain matin mais voilà oui
c'est important parce que c'est à la
fois une vitrine
et c'est en même temps d'une table de
revendications et d'expression de la
colère n'est annoncée comme l'a fait par
nicolas sarkozy un plan marshall pour
les agriculteurs pendant et en plein
pendant ce salon penser que c'est
vraiment autre chose qu'à d'abord
mesurer le pianiste nous avons tenu une
convention sur le monde agricole il ya
déjà un certain temps donc bien avant
bleus
le salon et nicolas sarkozy avait déjà
fait un discours où il parlait déjà de
ce plan marshall il n'a pas annoncé au
salon il a redit au salon ce qu'il avait
annoncé
dans cette convention dans le public un
jeu rappelle d'ailleurs qu'ici même au
sénat nous avons voté une proposition de
loi sur le monde agricole et sur la
défense agriculteurs et gérard larcher
il ya beaucoup tenu et il a eu raison et
donc nous ne découvrons pas le malaise
agricole avec le salon de l'agriculture
nous nous avons fait un certain nombre
de propositions je suis pas d'accord sur
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut pas
il faut à la fois des mesures urgentes
bien sûr et il faut des mesures
structurelles
parce que pardon mais on parle du
malaise agricole 2
agricoles tous les 2-3 ans depuis un
moment et vous concernant
la colère est maximum parce que tout
tout est convergent le fait qu'il y ait
l'embargo russe
le fait d'être extérieur laterrière vous
le fais pas dire aussi c'est la grande
distribution
oui mais pardon cette loi de 2008 elle a
été corrigé plusieurs fois sincèrement
on n'a pas découvert en 2016 les effets
de loi de 2008 donc ça je n'y crois
guère
je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'éléments structurels au niveau
européen qu'il faut évidemment changé
quand on dit dans notre reportage qui
s'est pas attardé monsieur phil hogan
dans les délais c'est vrai mais
paraissait très le retrouver mais
d'accord d'abord que ces crises et il
aurait pu passer tranquille dans le jeu
pose pas que les agriculteurs le
connaissent en réalité mais c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est que l'europe a
défini d'autres priorités que
l'agriculture c'était le point central
dans les années 60
ça ne l'est plus aujourd'hui donc il
faut voir comment re fait ça au niveau
européen
avoir une vraie politique agricole et
peut être mises de l'agriculture très
proche d amy j'y verse que c'était là
qu'à toute la semaine aux politiques
tout salon art et culture roger
karoutchi
les élus de droite n'ont fait que taper
sur stéphane fallu c'est le nouveau
bouquet michael vous montante ça
christiane taubira non moins avec un
quart noir moi me manque pas je jamais
été
ni vulgaire ni injurieux à son égard je
passerai pas téléphone je le serai pas
plus à l'égard de stéphane le foll
je trouve que le ministre de
l'agriculture a tort d'être à la fois le
ministre de l'agriculture est le porte
parole du gouvernement
quand on est de mise de l'agriculture on
se consacre au monde agricole on fait un
peu moins de politique un peu plus
d'agriculture et ce côté pardon un même
dans les séances de questions
d'actualité le soin au sénat ou à
l'assemblée très arrogant entre et je
fais tout je comprends pas pourquoi vous
parlez cinq hôtels à 100 quand on voit
la situation réelle des éleveurs et de
bien d agriculture un peu de modestie
dans les résultats et un peu de modestie
dans l'attitude ne nuit pas alors
mercredi toujours rire vous reparler de
cet amendement qui a été ajoutée puis
retirée du projet de loi sur la
biodiversité il prévoyait de supprimer
le principe du pollueur payeur il a
disparu sous la pression écoutez la
réaction de la ministre weil rien je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
montés au créneau
quelque part ça a permis de lancer l'
alerte mais de toute façon les
difficultés de rédaction c'est un moment
les aurait vus et on les aurait géré
encore une fois jamais au grand jamais
moi en tant qu'écologiste ni ségolène
royal ne laisserait passer une atteinte
quelconque ou une régression du droit de
l'environnement
alors comment est ce possible une telle
cacophonie
l'amendement qui se glissent comme ça ça
il ya toujours des amendements qui sont
ou des cavaliers ou des amendements de
lobby qui arrivent dans les textes
et là moi j'avais vu tout de suite
d'ailleurs c'était à l'assemblée et au
sénat mais j'avais eu tout de suite
la réaction des élus toutes couleurs
politiques confondues d'ailleurs par
exemple de bretagne qui disaient non
mais attendez
nous on s'est pris l'amoco cadiz le
torrey canyon et les autres vous croyez
quand même pas qu'on peut accepter ça
donc non ça arrive je partage totalement
leur avis il ya souvent une action des
lobbys pourtant qu'on a essayé de cadre
et d'un au parlement qui n'est pas
toujours très réussie c'est le moins
qu'on peut vivre et katia pas ce jeudi
puisque jeudi les députés vote de
nouvelles mesures antiterroristes dans
le cadre de la réforme pénale une
retenue de quatre heures après un
contrôle d'identité un assouplissement
de l'usagé des armes par les forces de
l'ordre encore un contrôle administratif
pour un individu qui revient du jihad
telles sont les mesures majeures voté
cette semaine par les députés on y
revient avec alex plichon les députés
sont rentrés dans le vif du sujet ils
ont donné leur feu vert à une retenue de
quatre heures après un contrôle
d'identité
une mesure qui a crispé dans les bancs
des écologistes et des frondeurs il faut
être bien naïf pour croire que la durée
de quatre heures n'est que de simples
vérifications vous introduisez vous-même
l'arbitraire dans la loi malgré quelques
voix dissidentes la droite prend fait et
cause pour la mesure certains
souhaiteraient même voir cette durée
allongée quatre heures ça risque d'être
un peu court
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de comparer les
fiches dans différents services
internationaux autre disposition phare
du projet de loi
l'assouplissement de l'usagé des armes
par les forces de l'ordre à la tribune
pascal popelin s'est voulu rassurant
l'objectif de cet article n'est en rien
une volonté de donner aux forces de
l'ordre
un permis de tuer mais pour le radical
alain tour et il n'est pas nécessaire de
modifier la loi
il y a systématiquement des
acquittements qui sont faits en matière
de légitime défense
eric ciotti lui s'est félicité de ce
considère comme une légère avancée vous
avez enfin souhaité répondre à nos
attentes dernières dispositions majeures
adopté la création d'un contrôle
administratif pour les individus de
retour du djihad pour lesquelles la mise
en examen n'est pas justifiée faute de
preuves
il ya eu beaucoup de mesures assez forte
votée à l'assemblée dans le cadre de ce
texte
c'est un bon texte équilibré ça répond à
la menace pour vous nous bon c'est un
texte qui est une avancée me dire que ça
répond à la menace sa soeur mort ce
franchement aller interroger français
dans la rue on leur dit alors les gens
qui reviennent du djihad rendais pas
compte mettre un contrôle administratif
déjà ils se disent on répond à la
terreur par la terreur bon c'est pas
assez
enfin voilà bon très bien pour le reste
les quatre heures à l'issue d'un
contrôle d'identité moi je trouve ça
assez normal l'attendait on nous dit
régulièrement tel ou tel est fiché dans
les services de renseignement est passé
au travers des mailles du filet laissons
au moins nos services pour travailler
comparer croiser les fichiers 4 heures
je ne sais pas si ça suffit mais en tout
cas faisons un peu les choses quant à
l'utilisation des armes par la police
enfin on est on est à l'envers quand
s'est passée la police de la république
c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya en a des milices
maintenant à la police on est où on
n'est pas au brésil on n'est pas dans
certains secteurs où on a des polices
parallèles c'est la police de la
république avec les règles de la police
les contrôles de la police et et on est
en train quasiment de leur dire oh là là
surtout vous avez quasi jeu dangereux
que des sondés fois globaux tous et il
ya des règles mais les règles internes
d'un soutien et résiste au feu on
assouplit les règles on dit
éventuellement on va pas vous mettre en
cause chaque fois et on va un peu
étendre les cas de légitime défense
est ce que pour autant non mais attendez
en fin de période toujours vrai si au
loin
de la grève pardon est ce que pour
autant vous pouvez toujours parler de
l'acsi mais c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure de la même manière qu'il ya
une cassure entre les libéraux et les
interventionnistes sur l'économie il ya
la ligne cazeneuve si je puis dire un
peu plus sensible quand même aux
problèmes de police et de sécurité et
des lignes est vraiment qu'au retrait de
la ligne du ministre de la justice
monsieur envoie également attendant il
est là depuis trop peu mais je pense que
l'actuelle garde des sceaux je trouve
que l'actuelle garde des sceaux semble
vouloir dire qu'il ne veut pas se mettre
en contradiction avec monsieur 15,9
chaque fois allez on revient bien en
arriver là c'est pour ça que vous parlez
de laxisme tout à l'heure en passer un
autre dossier c'est le dossier
migratoire qui était au coeur du 34e
sommet franco britannique qui a eu lieu
à amiens
françois hollande a mis en garde l'ong
contre la possibilité des conséquences
du brésil
par contre les britanniques ont donné un
peu plus d'argent pour aider notamment
sur la question des migrants face avec
clotilde hasard 22 millions pour
renforcer la sécurité à calais c'est la
somme que david cameron s'engage à
débloquer à amiens le premier ministre
britannique est resté ferme la manche je
dois rester infranchissable pour les
migrants nous avons des frontières
solide on nous les surveillons ensemble
pour dire aux gens qu'ils devraient
demander l'asile en france
s'ils ne le font pas ils devraient
retourner dans leur pays seule
concession
les mineurs isolés pourront rejoindre
leur famille outre manche mais seulement
celles déjà régularisés cette nouvelle
aide financière est la bienvenue pour
calais où la situation ne cesse de
s'enliser
la france gère au quotidien la
sécurisation du port et du tunnel sous
la manche mais aussi l'accueil des
migrants toujours nombreux et décidé à
rejoindre le royaume uni sur fond de
campagne pour le référendum sur le bric
site
françois hollande a tenu à rappeler
l'importance du rôle de la
grande-bretagne dans l'union européenne
à l'heure de cette grave crise
migratoire pas responsabilité c'est de
travailler avec le gouvernement
britannique pour que nous puissions
trouver les meilleures solutions pour
traiter la question des réfugiés
parce que ce qui est en cause là c'était
plus simplement la présence d'un pays
dans l'union européenne
c'est l'europe elle même qui est en
danger les deux pays ont par ailleurs
renforcé leurs relations bilatérales par
la signature d'un contrat d'armement et
d'énergie roger karoutchi je vous
présente ma t-il six roquettes avec
notre partenaire du scan qui va vous
poser quelques questions d'ici quelques
minutes
d'abord katia évidemment sur ce sommes
oui alors sur cette solidarité peut être
un peu forcée des anglais 22 millions
d'euros qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que l'entente cordiale où l'on
porte bien est ce que les britanniques
sont aux côtés de la france face à cette
grave crise est-ce que 22 millions
d'euros c'est suffisant
l'entente cordiale qui à 115 ans a subi
bien des coups de canif
non je pense que c'est vrai que les
britanniques ont intérêt à ce que ce
soit la france qui fasse le job pour eux
à la frontière que perdre at love
d'accord du tout à fait tout à fait mais
je ne conteste pas sauf que c'est pas 20
millions d'euros qui vont changer la
nature des choses sauf que la
responsabilité française elle est
d'avoir laissé se créer la jungle à
calais parce que il a eu affaire qu'à
laisser faire ou pas en parachute
il a évoqué les eaux traversées le pays
quand même donc un moment la
responsabilité autorités françaises de
savoir qui a le droit de demander
l'asile en france qui n'a pas le droit
d'être sur le territoire national avant
qu'ils arrivent à calais est une réalité
alors on semble on semble commencent à
prendre le problème du démantèlement de
la jungle
on verra jusqu'où ça va aller mais je je
je trouve que la position britannique
elle est à la fois confortable de dire
vous donne un peu d'argent mais vous
vous débrouillez et vous les garder chez
vous et d'un autre côté elle est
compliquée parce que est ce que les
britanniques vont quitter l'europe mais
je trouve que de toute façon les
britanniques négocié beaucoup mieux que
la france par rapport à l'europe
chaque fois qu'il ya quelque chose qui
va pas y re négocier en dia sinon ça va
et hop ils obtiennent des avantages ils
obtiennent des rééquilibrages jouanno
s'est élevé à e
money back de margaret thatcher
maintenant on a cameron qui se
débrouillent finalement pas mal et nous
à côté on fait quand même et 7
voit nos portes au coeur d'europe ça
veut dire mais non mais ça veut dire
qu'en réalité comme on a cassé pour
départ des mesures économiques mais
aussi par des mesures symboliques la
force de l'axé franco-allemand qui
construisaient l'europe
nous nous n'avons plus cette espèce de
poids d'un flux ans qui était le pois
franco allemand alors aujourd'hui on
négocie un peu avec les royaume uni ont
négocié un peu avec un email mais bon en
tout cas la france comme tout autre pays
va devoir accueillir des demandeurs
d'asile est ce qu'il ya des choses qui
sont faites
est-ce que vous avez des informations
non mais le gouvernement français
s'était engagé à dire 30 milles en juin
2015 sur l'année 2015 2016 ont durant
soit 30000 je reconnais que nous n'avons
ce qu'on appelle la relocalisation
qu'assez peu de syriens d'iraqiya en
réalité parce que c'est comme ça pour le
moment on a surtout nous les étudiants
des somaliens des soudanais
on a en réalité assez peu de gens qui
viennent des théâtres d'opération et
syrie irak
on nous dit que nos envoyés de l'ofpra
ou de l'office français d'immigration
dans les hot spots vont faire en sorte
qu' on en est davantage
moi ma crainte c'est que en réalité on a
augmenté de 25 % en 2015 le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile alors de grenat on
n'a pas la capacité de savoir combien on
en aura en 2016 et des gens parlent de
relocalisation d'un certain nombre de
séries à 10 opérations d sub et mais non
sa fin
sap a été financièrement anticipées on a
dit et j'ai voté pour
on va construire un peu de places
d'accueil mais pas assez par rapport à
une augmentation pareil
donc on va avoir comme disent le comme
du lycée allende heures des frictions en
2016-2017 des frictions ça veut dire
qu'on a des milliers
et de demandeurs d'asile qu'on ne sait
pas logés on a saturé les hôtels on a
saturé l'hébergement d'urgence
il viendra de places d'accueil j'en suis
rien paris le gouvernement non plus ça
sauf quelques rares ou quoi eh ben ça
fait craindre des incidents ça fait
quand des violences et moi je pense que
on n'a pas un programme de logements
suffisants et en même temps on n'a pas
un programme de contrôle suffisant parce
que si on peut pas les loger pas leur
donner de jobs et qu'on n'a pas d'argent
pour les allocations
à un moment il faut dire stop voilà je
vous dise matile sur route avec nous
elle attend depuis tout à l'heure c'est
la loupe du scan mathilde 0,7 à vous oui
bonjour roger karoutchi
vous faites partie des soutiens de
nicolas sarkozy pour la primaire vous le
pousser à se déclarer rapidement
candidat alors que lui souhaite attendre
l'été vous avez des jeunes et je crois
avec lui mardi
est ce que vous allez réussir à le
convaincre sur sa candidature sur le
calendrier il est lui le président de la
famille politique est bon il ya eu les
élections régionales les élections
internes du parti au mois de janvier
franchement le climat à l'intérieur du
parti est tel que il peut dire qu'il a
permis l'apaisement après les divisions
du passé
il ne souhaite pas entrer trop vite dans
le débat des primaires c'est au mois de
novembre
les français sont pas dessus pour ça que
quand je mets les autres façons déjà
dessus ça non pas la responsabilité la
famille politique donc ils peuvent aller
et venir dit
un doute sur la candidature du choléra
dans les plus de doute sur la
candidature
allez moi j'appelle à cette candidature
et sincèrement je le dis comme ça je
n'ai pas été le mieux traité du
quinquennat précédent 1 il y en a qui
ont été ministres beaucoup plus
longtemps que moi est mieux traité que
moi et qui aujourd'hui ne trouve que des
défauts au quinquennat précédent
moi j'ai toujours considéré comme à caen
jeudi
j'allais dire j'ai quitté le ministère
ne vous fait quitter le mystérieux
quittez pas de vous-mêmes sauf drame
bon quand on m'a fait quitter le mystère
vous n'avez entendu de ma part aucun mot
désagréable parce que c'était un honneur
d'être ministre mais c'est pas un dû et
c'est pas une propriété vous ne l'êtes
plus vous ne l'êtes plus points ça ne
change pas mes opinions sur le fait que
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour tous les
candidats et pour tous les responsables
avec qui je suis en bons termes
parce que ce sont des hommes d'état et
des hommes publics compétents mais en
même temps nous sommes dans une période
de crise
moi je crains je le dis franchement que
2016 2017 une aggravation de la crise
financière de la crise économie de la
crise du terrorisme de la crise
sécuritaire et je sais que dans ces
situations là il n'y a pas seulement la
qualité d'homme d'état qui va jouer il
ya la force et à la pugnacité
il ya la volonté et moi j'ai vu comment
nicolas a fait en 2008 quand il ya eu la
crise financière que les banques
s'écroulent et que l'économie
les économies des français allaient
disparaître je les ai vus me dire à moi
bien chargé des relations avec le
parlement
il me faut un accord du parlement avant
d'aller en allemagne négocier je le veux
en quatre jours je lui dis c'est
impossible c'est inconstitutionnel
on a réuni tous les présidents de
groupes de gauche et de droite à
l'elysée et nicolas sarkozy a obtenu au
moins chacun d'entre eux s'engagent à ne
pas faire de recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel s'était jamais vu jamais
vu qui peut faire ça pour sauver le pays
qui peut voilà c'est tout alors après
les autres tout le monde est très bien
j'aime tout le monde toujours un débat
de la primaire qui s'annonce quand même
assez rude pendant la campagne a pas
vraiment de rigidité à être publiées à
destination des candidats
si vous deviez le rédiger quel en serait
le premier prix le premier principe il
est clair pour tout le monde
nous appartenons à la même famille
politique presque tous ceux qui sont
déjà engagés dans cette primaire ont
appartenu au même gouvernement
alors on peut défendre ses convictions
défendre des idées un peu différente
pour autant c'est pas la peine de
petites phrases c'est pas la peine de
mots aigres-doux parce qu'au lendemain
de la primaire faudra tous se rassembler
pour assurer l'alternance en 2017 et
gagné contre la gauche voilà vous étiez
avec les militants des hauts de seine
mercredi soir et pour une consultation
sur le projet du parti
vous les avaient incités à faire des
propositions fortes oui et je vous cite
à secouer le cocotier
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
que vous trouvez que les responsables
politiques de droite sont trop frileux
sur le plan des idées pourquoi de droite
les responsables politiques en général
moi le premier parce que en fait sortez
dans la rue on va on va se prendre des
coups sur la tête enfin pas que nous
avons aussi le journaliste mais tout le
monde est discréditée
c'est les gens sont exaspérés les gens
ne croient plus dans la vie publique
il faut donc des propositions fortes
pour changer le système pour changer les
propositions pour rendre l'action
crédible pour faire en sorte que celui
qui sera élu président à binic en 100
jours changent tout parce que les gens
n'y croient plus donc oui il faut faire
des propositions et c'est pas une
question d'âge un j'entends des
commentaires en tout genre pour les
candidats à la présidentielle ce n'est
pas une question d'âge
une question d'état d'esprit qui veut
changer le pays qui veut faire en fait
en 2017 en 1958 moi je suis pour
allons-y alors avec natty qu'on va vous
interrogé aussi sur sa cette interview
donnée au magazine elle du président
l'avait remis à l'occasion de l'ag lui
qu'il était ministre toujours social mal
à cela
rebaptisé le ministère de la famille oui
il veut le rebaptiser en ministère des
femmes avaient vu ce matin la manif pour
tous en effet signé avec hervé mariton
député de la drôme des républicains pour
vous cela ce pluriel signifie quoi
qu'est ce que ça change je ne sais pas
enfin 6 de la symbolique pour faire
plaisir moi je n'ai pas voté la loi
taubira je n'ai pas voté contre je me
suis abstenu je te plutôt favorable à
l'article 1
un peu hésitant pour ne pas dire très
hésitant sur les articles sur
l'affiliation à l'adoption donc je me
suis abstenu mais sincèrement la famille
on peut la considérer comme on veut que
ça veut dire de passer de la famille à
l'effet matériel ça veut rien faire
différent alors que la famille soit
monoparentale homoparentale t'aidera
c'est la famille moi je suis pour une
politique familiale je supporte pas le
fait de fiscaliser des allocations
familiales ou de les baisser
je ne supporte pas le fait de baisser le
quotient familial c'était une force de
notre pays la république et au pluriel
ça vous plaît non moi je pense qu'on
aurait pu rester un ministère de la
famille et qu'à l'intérieur on pouvait
intégrer toutes les familles le fait je
vois pas sincèrement c'est du jeu j'ai
entendu laurence rossignol que je
respecte
d'autres qu'elle était sénatrice mais
que je respecte mais franchement
l'explication ne tient pas la route
merci merci à garantissez le mot de la
fin on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
même lieu même heure merci mathilde